(Intro) You are watching Coldfusion TV
Hi, Welcome to another Coldfusion video
It's no secret. That artificial intelligence is progressing rapidly. It seems like every couple of weeks
There's an unexpected development that takes people by surprise
It's starting to become clear that we're near the start of a new era that will include artificial
intelligence
Those people that aren't paying attention are likely to be taken aback by the things that are going to be possible in a Few years
Some voices have spoken out about the dangers and need for safety measures that must go along with developing powerful way
I one of the loudest voices of concern was that of Elon musk
in a strange twist elands non-profit artificial intelligence start-up
Which is called open AI and has just achieved a pretty remarkable feat in this video. We'll take a look at what's going on
So what's the background story?
Every year the game developer valve hosts the competition for expert players of the game dota 2 a popular online multiplayer game
The competition hosts professional players from all around the world all fighting for a twenty four million dollar Grand prize
this year there was a special guest competitor who wasn't human it was an AI trained by the engineers of Elon musk startup open AI
When put up one-on-one against one of the world's best players of dota 2 a crowd favorite Dendi the artificial intelligence one
Even a year ago. Nobody was sure if this kind of thing was possible
Dendi was surprised that an AI could outplay a human
He said that the AI quote felt like a human, but a little like something else end quote
this feat was achieved with just two weeks of real-Time learning by the AI
The engineers state that during this training period It accumulated
Lifetimes of experience they also state that the rules of dota are so complicated that if you just wrote down
Pre-Programmed rules and program some code to follow it the end result wouldn't even be as good as an average player
The artificial intelligence was trained from scratch with no knowledge of the game it played against itself over and over again until it had mastered
the game
How on Earth does a computer learn to play Delta? Yeah?
So this spot is quite unlike any what you've seen before
so
We've coached it to learn just from playing areas itself, so we didn't hard code in any strategy
We didn't have it learned from human experts just from the very beginning it just keeps playing
it's a copy of itself it starts from complete randomness, and then it makes very small improvements and
Eventually it is the pro. Level these are pro players these are human brain
So you just telling me this robot has failed so many times
It's actually better than professional dota players
it's played for really lifetimes of experience and
It's great so many games of dota. It's explored many different strategies learn to be learn to exploit other people who beat
and it's just played far more into the strategy space than any human as
Musk is hailing this achievement as the first time that artificial intelligence has been able to beat professionals in competitive esports
With esports being considered for the 2024 Olympics. This is certainly interesting
So this actually isn't the first notable achievement by open Ai they've actually done some pretty cool stuff in the past
The company actually invented a method where humans can interact with a robotic AI and teach it just like you would a human
here's how it works
First a human wears a Vr
Headset does a task and the robot watches and then imitates the task in real-time without ever having done it before
In this case it's learning how to stack some lego blocks that task sounds very simple for a human
But it's actually extremely hard for a machine to do this
The AI manages to do this by having its visual neural network trained on a large set of images of what blocks and simulated
environments could look like
This first visual neural network then sees the data to another neural Network called the Imitation Network
After this training and after just one single original demonstration of what to do the robot can now stack blocks?
even with different colored blocks placed in different positions every time
This means that the robot has to and does perform different actions to the scenarios than it's already seen
The end goal is to create an AI that can adapt to new and unpredictable environments
Okay, now back to open a is recent achievement
Elon has tweeted that his feet are feeding some of the best dota players in the world with an AI is a task much more
Complicated than chess or the board game go
Now I'm not so sure that I agree with Elon statement and esport is more complicated than go chess. Yes, definitely
Let's go perhaps. Not some state that goes the most Brilliant game ever made
Go is a 3000 year old Chinese board game in which an AI called alphago from the company deepmind
recently beat the World Champion in a series of playoffs
This event was held the biggest moment in artificial intelligence
Not expected for another decade. He is deepmind Ceo Dennis hasset us talking about some of the complexity of go
Nothing about goa. Is that he only has two rules I could teach you the game in five minutes
But it leads to incredible complexity. It's probably the most elegant game that mankind has ever devised
What happens in Asia and Career in Japan or and China?
Is if you show promise in the game of go of at the age of sort of five or six or seven?
You get taken out of normal school and get put into go school where you study go 12 hours a day seven days a week
With your peers who are also trying to become professional go players this has taken really seriously, and it's been like this
hundreds of Years
Now one way to illustrate the complexity of the game
Is that there are not more board configurations in the gamers go than there are atoms in the universe?
So there's no way that you can solve this game through broad group Force calculation
It's much too complex even if you took all the compute power in the world and you ran it for a million years
That wouldn't be enough computer power to calculate all the variations ingo
If children are literally pulled out of their school to spend half of their lives training to master this game
I can't really just dismiss it and say that dota 2 is more complicated although
Again that this could depend on your definition of combo. I hate it, but it's just something to think about on
the topic of Deep Mind
I imagine that some of you would be interested in a few juicy updates about what deep mind's alpha go is up to
Also, what has humanity learned from that moment when the Go world champion was defeated by an artificial intelligence?
Well while playing it's winning match against the go champion alphago played some very strange moves
They ended up giving it the advantage to win the match
To be clear in over 3,000 years of humans studying and playing go we've never thought of playing the way that alphago did
Alphago's moves have now been used in go schools to train students and expand their way of thinking about how to play the game and
Further to this deep Mayan plans on using the alphago algorithm for more general purpose
Functions as it shows great promise in its ability to learn and I think of AI is
This incredibly powerful tool that will augment human ingenuity and unlock our true potential
In fact one way you can think about AI and indeed alphago is like AI think of it as analogous to the hubble telescope
A kind of ultimate tool to explore the universe of course the go players alphago
Was allowing them to explore their universe of the game of go?
And I think there are many other domains
in the real world that suffer from this kind of combinatorial explosion that go has
Now obviously as I said at the beginning we test our systems on games because they're the most convenient way to develop our AI algorithms
But obviously ultimately we're not interested in just being good at games
We want to translate those algorithms into the real world and be useful and make huge impacts on real world situations
And one reason we could believe we can do that is because we're building general-Purpose learning systems
They're not being handcrafted for the get further. That's which. They'd like chess
They've actually we've actually built
We believe general-Purpose algorithms that could be taken from the games that we test them on and apply to real world
and we're applying these to all sorts of other areas healthcare robotics and even
Optimizing Data centers
So a variation of Alpha Go we took
Over last summer, and we applied it to Google's data centers, and we managed to save
15% of the power that was used in those data centers by controlling the cooling systems more efficiently.
So there you have it. As always it's some very interesting times in the field of artificial intelligence
It seems that artificial intelligence playing games would be a great way to enable it to learn,
but further to this, the knowledge learned could be applied in other field making the act of playing games
much more important than order first seem. Both Deep Mind and Open AI are going with this strategy. So
what's your view on the story?
Are you at all surprised by this or is this all just normal to you by now if you're a subscriber of this channel?
I'm sure you're pretty used to it.
Anyway, that's the end of the video.
Thanks so much for watching. If you've just stumbled across this channel feel free to subscribe.
This has been - go go you'll be watching cold fusion and I'll see you again soon for the next video
See you guys have a good one.
Cold Fusion, it's me thinking